Welcome back to Youtube Space New York.
I'm Jessica from comp Tom and I'm here on native laying talking about the
amazing intersection between language and code.
You should be excited because we're talking about passwords today and what your
password probably isn't as good as you think it is.
Okay,
right.
I love cookies,
but while they make the world's best dessert,
my apps keep rejecting chocolate chip is my password.
I will show you who's weak.
So I have to capitalize a letter at a number and maybe throw in some geometric
shapes and secret illuminati symbols.
Finally,
an acceptable password can.
I am never going to remember it.
So why the Internet's gives me the run around.
How exactly did password stop being?
Well,
words.
Welcome to comp chump.
The only show on the Internet where secrets in ye olden days,
the passwords worked a little differently.
You would walk up to that creepy I slit thingy and the people behind there would
slide it open and you had one shot to say the magic word,
but now you can just sit there spamming that paper with words.
You can throw unpronounceable nonwords at him and you could even knock on that
door from anywhere in the entire world because that Iceland is an innocent input
box and the people behind it is a computer and to computers.
Words are nothing special.
They're just boring old strings.
Character is appearing one after another after another after you get it.
So this is a valid string,
but so is this,
and even this,
which is an empty string,
there are so many possibilities,
but you know who doesn't actually see a string full of possibilities here the
humans like you and maybe me,
we fall back on our intuitive natural language to come up with strings that mean
something to us because we'd like to remember our passwords and if we're lucky
we might get super clever and like SWAPA letter for a number.
Behold my brilliance,
I took that three and used it as an e.
But you know what?
More often than not,
you are exactly as clever as the next guy and you're busy patting yourself on
the back for that.
Don't believe me,
just look at this list of most common passwords.
If you're a one of the the spies who used trust,
no one that's got to hurt.
Kind of felt like you came up with that one all on your own.
Did an it all is not lost.
If your password is on that list,
you can fix it.
It is time for you to do what programmers call getting entropy.
No,
get your mind out of the gutter that is computer speak for being less
predictable and how do you become less predictable by these random random,
you know what?
Maybe the next time you snooze your alarm and you wake up late,
you should just tell your boss you were trying to get some entropy.
Probably won't work and you might get fired,
but at least we'll all have a good laugh and the reason that you needed that
entropy is because hackers are getting better and better at predicting even
things that seem totally unpredictable.
You are can't keep hiding behind those little dots in asterisks.
I have so much trouble saying the word asterisks.
Trust.
No one tried to outwit them with a clever spelling and a complex character,
but why not just make your password longer in password cracking tests done by
one senior security consultant,
an eight character password took eight days to crack.
Adding just one extra character bumped that time up to 750 days and 11
characters that might take you get this 17,000 years.
Yeah,
that makes your bank account a little safer.
It's a long time for someone to try to get the dollar 50 that's left in my bank
account.
The thing is is that it might take 17,000 years because predicting is actually
about probability.
Look,
a hacker could randomly decide to start by guessing trust note too,
but they're going to go with that list of shame.
That includes trust no one and they're going to crack trust.
No one before trust note too,
even if it's just like right before because you know that the next sucker who's
password is getting hacked is trust.
No To linkedin funny characters.
They aren't the only things that make something guessable.
Take a look at this.
It's a nice random hard to guest string,
right?
Totally.
Totally not.
There is a pattern here.
Can you guess it?
Stop trying to guess with your eyes and guest with the eyes of your fingers
instead to de.
This is not the interview that you were looking for,
so I know how much it hurts to have to change your password every 90 days.
You can't reuse a previous password.
You can't use real words while blah,
blah,
blah.
I definitely feel it too,
but there is a good reason why passwords aren't real words anymore.
It's not because your computer hates English or because the programmer that made
that program really likes to give you the run around and make you play the
password recovery game every 90 days.
It's because words are predictable.
Subscribe to keep up with me and see more of the code behind our everyday lives.